[Applaus]
[Musik]
hermann jamaika eine insel mit
paradiesischen wetter und wunderschönen
stränden welche für reggae star bob
marley sprinter usain bolt und den
rastafari glauben bekannt ist
[Musik]
all diese kulturellen reichtümer kommen
von dieser winzigen insel mit etwa 3
millionen einwohnern
man könnte also sagen dass jamaika ein
kultur riesel ist und wer verdammt
nochmal würde seinen urlaub nicht gerne
mal in einem dieser schönen restaurants
in einem der amerikanischen strände
verbringt was ihr allerdings nicht so
häufig hören werdet sind sätze wie oh ja
ich werde mein geld im land von bob
marley anlegen oder meine firma schickt
mich in unser büro in kingston
tatsächlich würde ich jede wette
abschließen das will niemand hier auf
anhieb den premierminister oder die
währung jamaikas nennen könnte tja wenn
es um internationale lieferketten geht
ist jamaika so irrelevant für die
weltwirtschaft wie von bild hinauf
instagram für die hungernden dieser welt
jamaika ist zu arme wie armenien oder
die philippinen zumindest war es früher
so denn jetzt fangen die dinge an sich
zu ende
das team hat folgendes an
[Musik]
jamaika plant ein luftfracht und
logistikzentrum
die investoren planen ein handelszentrum
in der größenordnung singapurs du beißt
und rotterdams die vorstellung das
jamaica plötzlich von einem entspannten
dschungel bewachsenen inselparadies zu
einem boom standort wie singapur notiert
macht ehrlich gesagt etwas weit
hergeholt erscheinen aber wenn man
darüber ein wenig nachdenkt handelt es
sich dabei um eine großartige lösung für
seine etwas glanzlos wirtschaft und
jamaika ist dafür durchaus gut
aufgestellt schauen wir uns einfach mal
diese karte an welche die intensität des
schiffsverkehrs in der karibik darstellt
[Musik]
wie man unschwer erkennen kann liegt
jamaika in der nähe des panamakanals das
bedeutet dass viele schiffe an der insel
vorbei fahren oder dort sogar halten
machen müssen um zu tanken oder einen
teil ihrer ladung zu lagern ja es wäre
möglich diese dinge in panama selbst zu
erledigen aber diese dienstleistungen
sind dort mit der zeit immer teurer
geworden
dies erklärt warum kingston bereits
einen großen teil des schiffsverkehrs
einzeln konnte wenn man nur noch die
tatsache hinzufügt dass der panama kanal
in letzter zeit massiv ausgebaut wurde
und das jamaicas einzige konkurrenz nur
aus wirtschaftlich eher unattraktiven
beziehungsweise instabilen insel staaten
wie kuba und heidi besteht dann ist klar
dass jamaika hier eine echte chance
außerdem ist jamaika im gegensatz zu
seinen nachbarn ein englischsprachiges
land jede amerikanische investor der ein
lagerhaus eröffnung möchte könnte es
also nicht einfacher haben großartige
lage billige gehälter und alles auf
englisch
nun lautet die frage kann dies wirklich
eintreten kann jamaika ein
wohlstandsniveau erreichen dass zum
beispiel dem singapurs oder der
niederlande entspricht heute werden wir
diese fragen beantworten aber zuvor
wollen wir noch einen blick zurück in
die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
verlorener wohlstand am 6 august 1962
erlangte jamaika seine unabhängigkeit
vom britischen empire es handelte sich
um einen friedlichen übergang und es
wurde eine parlamentarische zwei
parteiendemokratie investmentstil
gebildet die bis heute hält die zukunft
sei damals für jamaica rosig aus die
1960 er jahre waren ein großes jahrzehnt
für den noch jungen start die wirtschaft
verlagerte sich weg von der
landwirtschaft hin zum bauxit abbau zum
tourismus und zur fertigung von
produkten auf basis gering qualifizierte
arbeitskräfte und so privaten
investitionen damals in den 60er jahren
boomte die amerikanische wirtschaft und
wuchs durchschnittlich mit sechs prozent
pro jahr
es schien als würde der postkoloniale
traum wahr werden
doch leider haben sich die dinge in den
siebziger jahren zum schlechteren
gewendet das wachstum der weltwirtschaft
verlangsamte sich damals und zog diese
kleine insel mit sich die wachsende
wirtschaftliche ungleichheit und der
groll gegen die postkolonialen eliten
geführt und dazu dass ein demokratischer
sozialist namens michael manly die
wahlen gewann
dies bedeutete eine verschiebung in den
internationalen beziehungen jamaika
neigte sich der sowjetunion zu und legte
eine agenda gegen die freie
marktwirtschaft auf das start begann
preise zu kontrollieren grundbesitzers
seinen eigenen mindestlöhne anzuheben
und öffentliche ausgaben auszuweiten
theoretisch hätten viele dieser reform
den amerikanern gut spielen können mein
lieferte großartige dinge wie kostenlose
staatliche bildung mutterschaftsurlaub
und alle arten von sozialprogrammen
[Musik]
aufgrund der preiskontrollen und der
markt beschränkung jedoch konnten all
diese guten absichten nie verwirklicht
werden männlich offen den kubanischen
kommunistischen führer fidel castro
lobte hat sich auch nicht gerade bemüht
die beziehungen zu den usa wieder
geradezubiegen infolgedessen zogen sich
die ausländischen investoren fast
vollständig zurück und die mittelschicht
verließ das land in scharen ein
regelrechter brain brain setzte ein und
nur die unqualifizierten blieben im land
zurück in diesen jahren stieg die
inflationsrate auf zweistellige beträge
und die preiskontrollen führten zu einer
regelmäßigen verknappung auch der
grundlegendsten güte 1980 schließlich
hatten die amerikaner männliches lehre
sozialutopisten versprechende satt und
sie wählten ihn ab nun entschieden sie
sich jedoch für das entgegengesetzte
extrem der rechtsextremist adwords
seeger übernahm die macht und machte den
usa und dem vereinigten königreich den
hof jamaika rupp nicht mehr costolo in
den himmel sondern halt den usa im jahr
1983 bei der invasion des
kommunistischen grenada und ich weiß
dass viele von euch gleich denken mögen
gleich nachdem jamaika anfängen sich den
usa anzudienen wendete sich alles wieder
zum guten läuft das nicht so in der
politik nun die realität ist wie immer
viel viel komplizierter
kombiniertes chaos maker ist der ort an
dem man seine sorgen vergessen kann so
sehr das no problem oder wie es im
amerikanischen dialekt heißt ja mal ein
slogan ist der fest mit esel assoziiert
wird und nein
ja man bedeutet nicht jammern sondern
wie gesagt kein problem das ironische
dabei ist jedoch dass jamaika in
wirklichkeit viele probleme hat viele
wirklich große probleme ihr make-up
verlängert ausnahmezustand reisewarnung
wegen hohen niveaus von gewaltverbrechen
es wäre eine bodenlose untertreibung zu
sagen das jamaica ein land voller hass
und gewalt ist es fällt einem wirklich
schwer sich vorzustellen wozu die
menschen unter diesen paradiesischen
himmel in der lage sind die mordrate in
jamaika ist achtmal so hoch wie der
weltweite durchschnitt im jahr 2005
hatte jamaika 58 morde pro 100.000
menschen was die höchste rate der welt
in diesem jahr war bis 2017 gegen sich
zurück und zwar genau um einen mord pro
100000 also auf 57 pro 100000 einwohner
damit ist jamaika nur noch das zweite
land nach el salvador und knapp vor
venezuela ein ehemaliger premierminister
nannte das thema kriminalität eine
nationale herausforderung von
beispiellosen ausmaßen dieses problem
ist nicht neu die entwicklung begann
mitte der 1970 er jahre als beide großen
politischen parteien begannen städtische
gangs tollen weise mit waffen und geld
auszustatten damit sie als
paramilitärische schlägertrupps ihrem
jeweiligen politischen gegner ordentlich
einheizen ein genialer schachzug im
wahlkampf nicht wahr
das ergebnis war wie man erwarten konnte
viele viele tote sehr sehr viel
schweden kam hinzu dass die usa damit
begonnen waffen an die arbeitspartei und
ihre banken zu liefern und ebenso begann
kuba und die udssr damit waffen an die
banken der nationalpartei zu liefern
ja ihr habt richtig gehört ich habe das
im letzten satz nicht einfach
verwechselt in jamaika heißt die rechte
partei labour party und die linke
national party bis 1980 kam fast 800
menschen bei politischen morden ums
leben oft ging es um
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
verschiedenen stadtteilen von kingston
die jeweils politisch auf der
entgegengesetzten seite standen auch
heute noch unterstützen die politischen
parteien verbrecherbanden aber die gänge
sind heute weit weniger abhängig von den
parteien sondern vielmehr von der
kolumbianischen drogenmafia
es ist also nicht überraschend dass die
kriminalitätsrate überhaupt nicht
gesunken ist und auch was die
amerikanische wirtschaft angeht finden
die hier nicht gerade strukturen vor die
man als rosig bezeichnen könnte die esel
jamaika hat der welt nicht viele
ressourcen zu bieten meist nur zucker
kaffee und auch sieht außerdem sind dies
alles wo produkte die für sich allein
genommen nicht viel wert sind und
international starker konkurrenz
ausgesetzt sind ein großer teil der
wirtschaft basiert auf dem tourismus
dieser ist jedoch oft löslichen und
schnellen schwankungen ausgesetzt wie zb
aufgrund von den verwüstungen durch
harry nicht gerade ein stabiles
fundament die problematik der schwachen
und nicht besonders wettbewerbsfähigen
exportwirtschaft wird noch dadurch
verschärft dass das land ja fast alles
importieren muss lebensmittel
medikamente maschinen was auch immer
alles wird von außen importiert an der
spitze der import liste steht das erdöl
von dem jamaika in hohem maße abhängig
ist dadurch zählt ja mei karte den
ländern mit den höchsten energiekosten
all diese faktoren summieren sich zu
einem gigantischen handelsdefizit im
jahr 2017 betrug dieses 4,5 milliarden
us dollar das ist eine riesensumme für
ein land mit weniger als drei millionen
menschen und einem bruttoinlandsprodukt
von nur 15 milliarden dollar umgerechnet
bedeutet dies dass jeder jamaikaner im
jahr war ca 5000 dollar erwirtschaftet
gleichzeitig jedoch unterstrich ein
drittel davon 1600 dollar für immer ist
ausland abfliessen ja für jahr und was
fragt ihr euch ist das ergebnis der
kombination dieses riesigen
außenhandelsdefizits hoher preise für
güter des täglichen bedarfs und einer
sozialistischen misswirtschaft eine der
schlimmsten horror version jeder
volkswirtschaft stagnation ja stagnation
eines dieser kohlen wörter die man hier
bei visual politik lernen kann
toll was
[Musik]
von stagnation spricht man wenn bei
stagnierendem wirtschaftswachstum und
hohe arbeitslosenzahlen auch noch eine
hohe inflationsrate herrscht ein land
was in eine stagnation gerät ist eine
ganz besondere weise in einer
ausweglosen situation denn normalerweise
ist es so dass wenn die wirtschaft
schlecht läuft und damit die
arbeitslosigkeit steigt die zentralbank
des landes einfach den geldhahn
aufdrehen kann das heißt die wirtschaft
mit geld versorgt die können dann mehr
investieren und arbeitsplätze schaffen
mehr geld im wirtschaftskreislauf erhöht
jedoch die inflationsrate also wird die
zentralbank sobald die wirtschaft wieder
rund läuft den geldhahn wieder abdrehen
um die preise wieder ins lot zu bringen
besonders dumm es ist nur wenn ein land
bereits eine hohe inflationsrate
aufweist und die wirtschaft in dieser
situation in eine rezession bewegt
dann kann die zentralbank den geldhahn
nämlich nicht noch weiter auf denn
dadurch könnte es zu einer vollkommen
und panikartigen geldentwertung kommen
das ganze währungssystem des landes und
damit das vertrauen der mensch darin
dass hier geld überhaupt noch
irgendeinen wert hat würde kollabieren
und eine wirtschaft ohne geld würde
wieder auf einen hochgradig
ineffizienten tauschenden zurückfallen
und damit auch ein prähistorisches level
von produktivität und lebensstandard
märkte also stagnation ist eine total
verfahrene situation und ganz schlecht
für die menschen eines landes
[Musik]
so und nach dieser kostenlosen
makroökonomie vorlesung ist es an der
zeit euch zu bitten die waldpolitik auch
zu abonnieren als ihr dies noch nicht
getan habt und drückte auch auf die
klingel damit ihr keine beiträge
verpasst aber komplett zurück in die
idylle von jamaika mit seiner üblen
stagnation seit etwa 50 jahren erlebt
dieses land eine ausufernde inflation
und gleichzeitig chronische
arbeitslosigkeit das ist eine verdammt
lange zeit zwei oder drei verlorene
generationen und obwohl jamaica stark in
seine unabhängigkeit vom britischen
empire gestartet ist verbrachte es nun
mehr als 80 prozent dieser zeit in einem
wirtschaftlichen teufelskreis man dachte
in jamaica dass sich die probleme schon
lösen würden wenn man nur genug
ausländischen investoren für die
entwicklung der tourismusbranche ins
land locken würde aber mit so hohen
preissteigerungen und einer furchtbar
hohen kriminalitätsrate würde noch nicht
mal ein sudanesischer flüchtling nach
jamaica gehen geschweige denn die
geldsäcke von der wall street aber hört
jetzt genau zu denn der wind der
veränderung könnte die eingemotteten
segel jamaikas gerade jetzt mit einer
frischen brisen versorgen die regierung
hat eine neue nationale strategie
verabschiedet und dieser hat das
potenzial die wirtschafts makers nicht
nur wieder zu beleben sondern sie in
eine perle der sieben weltmeere zu
verwandeln
lage lage und nochmals lage der 26 juni
2016 war ein großer tag für die welt und
die karibik eine sehr großes schiff fuhr
durch den panamakanal viel viel größer
als jemals zuvor ja das war der tag an
dem die lang erwartete erweiterung des
panamakanals endlich verzogen war diese
erweiterung hat die kapazität des kanals
fast verdoppelt und führte zur schaffung
einer ganz neuen schiffsklasse der neo
pedelecs diese definiert die größe eines
schiffes das nach der neuen maximal
spezifikation des kanals gebaut wurde
in den nächsten 20 monaten würden über
3000 dieser neuen schiffe den kanal
überqueren was dann zu solchen
nachrichten geführt hat
anteil der karibik an der globalen
fracht industrie wächst rasant fort im
mai 2009 10 und wo frage ich euch wollen
all diese stehen nun so ziemlich überall
sie transportieren zum beispiel waren
von china nach florida oder von spanien
nach ecuador und umgekehrt in vielen
fällen werden sie an jamaika der nächst
gelegenen insel direkt vorbeifahren oder
dort so gehalt machen doch warum fragt
ihr euch sollten sie ausgerechnet in
jamaika anhalten nun einige dieser
schiffe möchten ihre waren
möglicherweise für einige zeit lagern
oder auf andere schiffe umladen bevor
oder nachdem sie den panama kanal
passiert haben andere müssen
möglicherweise neue betankt und gewartet
werden und panama ist bereits voll eine
insel in der nähe zu haben ist äußerst
praktisch und deshalb wird jamaika aus
seiner lage kapital schlagen und zu
einem transit knoten werden nicht nur
amerika sondern für die ganze welt alles
was es braucht ist ein haufen
infrastruktur wie häfen eisenbahn und
flughäfen zusammen mit einrichtungen wie
trockendocks für die schiffsreparatur
nun steht jamaika damit in gewissen
wettbewerb mit anderen karibischen
staaten was die unter druck setzt
schnell zu handeln aber wenig glück wird
jamaika seine nachbarn sind nicht gerade
topfit heidi und kuba wären natürliche
konkurrenten aber das eine land befindet
sich gerade auf dem chaos niveau
somalias also sogar noch viele viele
zivilisations stufen unterhalb der
neckar und der andere konkurrent kuba
wird noch immer von ewiggestrigen
kommunisten regiert die sich mit
rigorosen us sanktionen konfrontiert
sehen dann gibt es noch puerto rico ein
us territorium dessen derzeitige
regierung jedoch vollkommen
handlungsunfähig ist und schließlich die
dominikanische republik die so ziemlich
die einzige ist die mit jamaika
konkurrieren könnte aber wenn jamaika
das schafft was er sich vorgenommen hat
wird es groß nicht nur in der karibik
sondern auf globaler ebene wenn alles
klappt wird jamaica von der total miete
zum überflieger werden stellt euch vor
wie es wäre wenn sich dieses arme land
wirklich ins nächste singapur verwandeln
könnte glaubt ihr dass klänge zu
tollkühnen
das glauben wir nicht es hat wirklich
eine chance wenn es nicht im fahrzeug
jamaika ist eine weitgehend stabile
englischsprachige demokratie und
mitglied des commonwealth of nations
aber nicht dass es ist umgeben von des
funktionalen volkswirtschaften und
grenzwertigen feld stakes und das zu
einem zeitpunkt der den beginn eines
goldenen zeitalters der karibischen
schifffahrt markiert
und einen teil der arbeit hat ja schon
erledigt indem ist nämlich bereits das
land für die neuen hefen eisenbahnlinien
und sonderwirtschaftszonen erschlossen
hat für das projekt werden investitionen
in höhe von etwa 28 milliarden us-dollar
angestrebt die amerikanische regierung
die weltbank und mehrere private partner
haben bereits zusagen gemacht und
beiträge geleistet die amerikaner wären
aber nicht die einzigen die davon
profitieren würden mit der entwicklung
neuer infrastruktur könnte mehr ladung
schneller verschifft werden dies würde
die kosten für viele menschen auf der
welt senken und damit den wettbewerber
erhöhen und besserer wettbewerb im
internationalen handel könnte dann zum
beispiel bedeuten dass in europa
frischeres und leckeres obst aus
südamerika zu kaufen ist und die
kanadische hilfe venezuela würde
schneller und billiger an ihr ziel
kommen jamaika würde also ein aufschwung
erleben von dem fast alle auf der welt
etwas hätten so was meint ihr wird das
alles funktionieren wird diese neue sehr
teure infrastruktur wirklich gebaut
werden wird kingston in die liga der
elite weltstädte wie singapur aufsteigen
oder ist jamaika dazu verdammt in seinem
truck des kreis von kriminalität und
armut zu verharren könntet ihr euch zum
beispiel vorstellen jetzt nach der major
auszuwandern
dann könnte man nicht nur das
wundervolle wetter genießen sondern auch
an den wirtschaftlichen boom und am
bedarf viele qualifizierte arbeitskräfte
dort präsidieren und wenn es nicht
klappt mit dem wirtschaftsaufschwung
hätte man zumindest eine schöne zeit am
meer verbracht wie immer freuen wir uns
auf eure eloquenten und äußerst bedacht
samen kommentare und wisst ihr dass jede
woche neue frisch und informative videos
für euch vorbereitet und veröffentlichen
wenn er also keines dieser aktuellen
updates verpassen wollt abonniert bitte
visual politik und drückt danach auch
auf das glück wenn ihr euch dieses video
gefallen hat geht uns einen daumen hoch
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]